pour un créateur le dessin c'est
fondamental
c'est le chemin le plus direct entre
l'idée et la mise en forme de l'idée
donc le chemin direct c'est le bras le
stylo au commencement il y à un dessin
toujours ce n'est qu'une esquisse
mais benoît fublaines pose ainsi ses
idées sur le papier
actuellement je suis en train de
plancher pour une grande maison maison
de
la place vendôme donc des joaillier et
c'est pour faire une installation avec
des papillons en céramique meilleur des
centaines de papillons et je travaille
sur le signe de l'infinité infiniment
précieuse qui correspond à la joyeuse
avec ses mobiles
l'artiste travaille sur le mouvement que
crée le fil de fer il joue avec la
transparence et la lumière du cristal il
a étudié aux beaux-arts
ensuite il a enseigné les arts
plastiques et la peinture en vacances
dans les cévennes n'ayant pas mon
matériel de peintres ayant du fil de fer
sous la main j'ai commencé à construire
les premiers luminaires en fait donc
j'ai utilisé sur un fil de fer donc
comme je viens de le dire qui permet de
dessiner dans l'espace et puis au mieux
de mettre des pampilles à facettes
j'avais trouvé des blocs de cristal brut
que j'ai cassé au burin et qui ont en
fait dessiner c'est pampilles j'ai
revisité l'idée qu'on peut se faire
manuscrits anciens à pampilles
[Musique]
notre créateur aime revisiter et
détourner les objets comme ces
mappemonde qui retrouve une seconde vie
[Musique]
l'artiste n'a pas oublié son âme
d'enfant
son univers ce sont aussi ces sourds et
qu'il met en scène
entre cirque et danse entre poésie et
imaginaire